vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins il
du bon vieux cash nous vous parlerons de
tout sans langue de bois
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
petit coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité les ide et
courageuse des mots qui comptent
en soi vient de l'ignorance aujourd'hui
on a une gauche extrême
[Musique]
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
comment abordez vous cette épreuve vous
êtes vous rendu au procès je suis allé
aux premières auditions du procès j'ai
trouvé vraiment que le monde finalement
été formés de gens merveilleux et de
aidé de jean ignoble en fait vous ne
savez pas comment votre fils est mort
vous devez enquêter sur tout et vous
confronter
ils étaient ni sur la liste des morts
nés sur la bbc une surveillance et
hopitalisé il était nulle part est ce
qu'on peut vivre malgré cette douleur
quand j'ai écrit à la fois je souffrais
parce que ça me rappelait des beaux
souvenirs avec stéphane et en même temps
c'était très douloureux et puis
aujourd'hui je me suis aperçu que ça
permettait d'extraire de moi même toute
cette histoire est donc ça m'a apporté
un peu de recul un peu d'apaisement mais
la douleur et la colère seront là
jusqu'à ma mort
[Musique]
le quinquennat d'emmanuel macro
aura-t-il eu sur le pouvoir d'achat des
ménages français on m'a toujours
sous-évalué le rythme de l'inflation et
donc on peut vous chantez que le pouvoir
d'achat a augmenté
la réalité c'est qu'il abaissait le
pouvoir d'achat l'huile dé 0 1% là sur
riesch a énormément augmenté qu'est ce
qu'il faut pour avoir du pouvoir d'achat
partagé pour la programmation bien la
seule manière de faire c'est une
activité privée dynamique et permet de
distribuer des revenus suffisants pour
faire face au coût de la vie et la
réalité c'est que sur ce plan rien n'a
été fait vous faites de la dette comme
ça et quand vous imprimer des billets
comme ça vous fléché 2 fait sur les gens
qui détiennent le capital
donc ça arrive de fait sur les marchés
par exemple l'action ça fait monter les
titres mais ça ne m'apporte rien dans
notre assiette
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple sap
est une volonté collective vous le savez
comme moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y a pas
d'alternative au sort du politique il
est clair que tout le monde attend saft
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre de mesures un
peu autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez déçu l'univers
uniforme c'est quand même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose dignité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite c'était
des gens qui travaillent c'est les gens
qui avaient envie de transmettre quelque
chose à leurs enfants
[Musique]
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas la double hic
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est on dirait qu'il ya quand
même la liberté je vous remercie de
m'avoir invité
[Musique]
bonsoir at-on s'annonce sommes ensemble
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à 21h30 pour décrypter les grands
titres de l'actualité de la journée au
sommaire de ce jeudi 2 décembre qui de
eric ciotti ou valérie pécresse
représentera la droite républicaine à
l'élection présidentielle ces deux
personnalités se sont donc qualifiés
pour le deuxième tour du congrès des
républicains qui s'achèvera samedi
xavier bertrand qui passait pour le
mieux placé à droite a finalement été
éliminé tout comme michel barnier marine
le pen s'est dite satisfaite de le voir
hors course alors les cartes de la
présidentielle sont elles rebattu tout
est encore possible
on attend vos réactions sur le comté de
g berthet france
le variant omicron risque de devenir
majoritaires en europe dans les tout
prochains mois alerte cet après-midi de
l' agence de l'union européenne chargée
des maladies en france métropolitaine
deux cas ont été confirmés et une
dizaine d'autres examinent est
confrontée à la reprise épidémique
certains hôpitaux d'ailleurs déclenché
leur plan blanc un nouveau conseil de
défense de sécurité se tiendra lundi en
fin de matinée
les retraités demandent un meilleur
niveau de vie venus de toute la france
ils ont manifesté aujourd'hui à paris à
l'appel de neuf syndicats une s'estime
la revalorisation de leur pension trop
faible eu égard à l'inflation côté
gouvernement emmanuel macron confirmé le
mois dernier qu'il n'y aurait pas de
réforme des retraites le temps de la
pandémie mais le projet projet n'est pas
enterré pour autant alors à quoi peut-on
s'attendre éléments de réponse tout à
l'heure avec les hits aux échos de
jacques c'est pire
[Musique]
mais avant de développer ses titres
petit détour dans la capitale suédoise
où vient de se dérouler une entrevue
tendues entre les chefs des diplomaties
russe et américaine en marge de la
réunion annuelle de l'ouest c'est eux on
retrouve notre envoyé spécial david
kelly fort direct de stockholm bonsoir
david elle ce soir ça caille lavrov a
donc tenu une conférence de presse après
cette réunion ce matin
effectivement une conférence de presse
juste après sa rencontre avec anthony
habib kane a le chef de la diplomatie
américaine il a une nouvelle fois fait
part de son désarroi remise à vis de
l'otan face au manque de considération
des propositions russes pour la paix il
accuse l'alliance atlantique de
continuer à rapprocher son
infrastructure militaire des frontières
russes est appelée à à trouver une
solution dans le cadre d'un dialogue
avec les états unis et leurs alliés
c'est ce dont il a été question durant
son entretien avec anthony blinken 1 cet
après midi l'objectif est de trouver un
équilibre
un équilibre des intérêts dans cette
région mais le chef de la diplomatie
russe dénonce le comportement agressif
de l'occident envers la russie la
cordialité ne fait plus partie des
priorités européennes selon ses mots il
espère que le sc eux pourra changer la
donne en ce sens à savoir que joe biden
et vladimir poutine elle devrait se
parler ces prochains jours pour évoquer
cette escalade de tension à la frontière
ukrainienne et merci david pour ce petit
point en direct de stockholm ans était
un avant goût puisque on vous retrouvera
dans une demi heure pour une analyse
plus complète sur cette rencontre et ses
enjeux qui sont extrêmement importants
sur le plan géopolitique merci à vous et
à tout à l'heure
en attendant l'actualité politique en
france dominée par la qualification des
candidats pour le deuxième tour chez les
républicains eric ciotti et valérie
pécresse savent compteront donc pour
devenir les leaders de l'est républicain
dans la course à la présidentielle et le
député des alpes-maritimes de vence d'un
cheveu la présidente de la région ile de
france katia technique
cela s'est joué à quelques voix près
entre eric ciotti valérie pécresse
arrive en troisième position michel
barnier est suivi par xavier bertrand
philippe juvin bon dernier obtient à
peine 3% des suffrages on écoute le
détail le philippe juvin a recueilli
3532 voix
3,13 %
xavier bertrand a recueilli 25 mille
deux cent treize voix
22,36 %
michel barnier a recueilli 26
1970 voit
23,93 % valérie pécresse
a recueilli 28 mille
179 voix 25% eric ciotti a recueilli 28
1844 voix 25 59 % donc seront à
départager au deuxième tour qui va
s'ouvrir dès demain matin à 8 heures
eric ciotti et valérie pécresse les
adhérents doivent voter dès demain pour
départager les finalistes alors les
candidats malheureux xavier bertrand
michel barnier philippe juvin appellent
de leur côté à se ranger derrière
valérie pécresse pas de soutien chez les
ténors dlr pour eric ciotti qui est
pourtant en tête de ce premier tour le
candidat finaliste veut en tout cas
rassembler le peuple de droite comme a
su le faire nicolas sarkozy en 2007 at
il dit eric ciotti déclarent être en
mesure de faire barrage à emmanuel
macron ou encore marine le pen alors
justement la candidate du rassemblement
national y est allé de son petit
commentaire sur la fiche des finalistes
l heure on a le choix entre immigration
et natalité mon choix est fait c'est pas
d'immigration et de la natalité et je
viens dire à ceux qui sont les plus
aisés de nos compatriotes vous devez
participer à cette politique de natalité
parce qu'il en va de l'avenir de votre
pays de notre pays et je suis convaincu
qu'ils accepteront cette philosophie
elle s'est dite satisfaite des résultats
et surtout de la défaite de xavier
bertrand selon marine le pen je cite il
a toujours exprimé une hostilité à la
limite de la haine à l'égard du rn fin
de citation des propos tenus en main
d'une conférence de presse sur le
chiffrage de ces mesures sur
l'immigration pour marine le pen
rarement un pays n'aura été si généreux
au point de se ruiner et d'un beau
donner ses propres enfants attaque à
peine voilée contre la politique
migratoire du gouvernement actuel la
présidente du fn qui affirment aussi
vouloir faire l' inverse des manuels
macron concernant la position des foyers
les plus fortunés elle souhaite revenir
à un impôt sur la fortune dont seraient
exonérés certains biens immobiliers et
patrimoniaux la candidate du
rassemblement national n'est pas tendre
non plus avec eric zemmour selon elle la
candidature du polémiste est inutile et
sans élan marine le pen estime qu'eric
zemmour n'apporte pas de plus value
supplémentaire aux idées de son parti le
polémiste qui semble d'ailleurs bien
affaibli après la publication de son
clip d'entrer en campagne aujourd'hui
youtube a décidé d'interdire la vidéo
mineurs et pour l'instant la plateforme
ne peut pas retirer la vidéo pour
violations des droits d'auteur une
dizaine de médias et sociétés de
production ont fait un signalement pour
atteinte aux droits d'auteur auprès de
youtube c'est le cas notamment du
quotidien le parisien ou encore du
distributeur de cinéma gaumont eric
zemmour qui a aussi provoqué la colère
de laeticia hallyday la veuve de johnny
accuse candidate de détournement de
l'image du chanteur décédé et elle
envisage des poursuites et qui
représentera donc les airs à la
présidentielle qui peut battre emmanuel
macron avec eric ciotti ou valérie
pécresse chez les républicains les
cartes peuvent elles être rebattues
présidentielle tout est encore possible
on attend vos réactions sur le comté d g
d'ayrté france et place au décryptage
[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler mais rick
guise et secrétaire général adjoint du
think tank le millénaire bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous sur ce plateau en
direct stéphane le rudulier porte parole
d'eric ciotti merci d'être avec nous ce
soir également en direct un pour les
spécialistes dont benjamin morel docteur
en sciences politiques bonsoir benjamin
morel et puis nous rejoindra rendant
dans quelques minutes votre nouvel
adversaire amical certes l'adversaire
tout de même pour quelques jours jean
philippe dugoin clément porte parole de
valérie pécresse bonsoir et merci d'être
là à tous alors c'est un petit peu quand
même la surprise du jour on imagine que
vous êtes un homme heureux ce soir eric
relié
le député a l'air donc des êtres
maritime qui s'est qualifié avec valérie
pécresse pour le second tour de la
primaire je vous propose tout d'abord de
l'écouter
j'ai voulu placer cette campagne sous le
signe de la vérité de la vérité sur la
situation
d'un pays en voie de déclassement de
déclin sur la clarté des alliances
jamais d'alliance hier aujourd'hui et
demain avec le maquereau 10 mhz et puis
sur le courage d'un vrai projet de
rupture eh bien je crois que cette
vérité cette clarté ce courage
ont
mobilisé ont mobilisé le soutien de nos
militants alors que j'étais loin très
loin même
d'être favori et que pendant des
semaines
les commentateurs que vous êtes m'avait
ranger dans la seconde catégorie des
candides en seulement d'un petit peu de
rancune stéphane leur est dédié non pas
eric à eric c'est lui
c'est vrai qu'il a déjoué tous les
pronostics aujourd'hui eric ciotti on
l'a qualifié souvent de droite dure ça
veut dire quoi c'est le retour de la
droite forte au sein des dlr non je
pense que c'est le candidat qui a
véritablement le mieux parler aux
militants par rapport à ses convictions
et la sincérité de son engagement et à
respecter en fait l'adn qui était en
fait celui du rpr de l'époque des années
90 il en faisait déjà allusion à bon
nombre de reprises dans le cas de ces
réunions publiques et ça ça récompense
aussi la fidélité d'eric ciotti à son à
son parti
quarante années de militantisme et je
pense que les militants lui ont dieu
comme il se devait c'est ce qui a péché
chez xavier bertrand son infidélité
à fait les mêmes chaussures comme chacun
tirera les conclusions qu'ils vont tirer
effectivement eric ciotti quel que soit
d'ailleurs l'état de notre parti
politique dans des soirs de victoire
comme dans des soirs de défaite était
toujours toujours aux côtés des
dirigeants de sa famille pour essayer de
relever le flambeau et de reprendre le
combat idéologique pour faire gagner nos
idées et je pense que c'est grâce à cela
également grâce à la force de ses
convictions et à la sincérité de son
engagement le savez les débats les
quatre débats le premier débat a été une
révélation pour un bon nombre d'entre
nous par rapport à l'engagement de
d'eric ciotti avait pas de faux semblant
il n'y avait pas de non-dits ni
d'imprécisions dans son projet tout
était dit mais qu'il avait rien à perdre
aussi peut-être oui mais même il y avait
une clarté dont diagnostic et puis comme
il le dit dans son propre programme et
c'est cette question de fameux gant
remplacement qu'avait été posée à
l'époque par une 2 1 de vos homologues
il y a répondu c'est pas un problème de
vocabulaire s'il fallait dire grand
remplacement disons le mais voilà mes
solutions mais je pense que ça a été
appréciée au niveau des militants
benjamin morel en attendant les perdants
ont rallié very pécresse xavier bertrand
michel barnier philippe juvin ils ont
fait le choix de rejoindre la candidate
selon eux les mieux placés pour
l'emporter
ciotti se retrouve un petit peu seul
contre tous et un vote utile qui se
profile sheller selon vous
c'est pas tout à fait évident c'est à
dire que aujourd'hui vous avez un
exotique est probablement beaucoup plus
à l'image d'un point de vue idéologique
la base des militants à la base des
adhérents air et donc il peut y avoir un
choix de la raison dans un choix valérie
pécresse si vous prenez les enquêtes
d'opinion en vue de la présidentielle il
peut y avoir un choix du coeur pour une
grande partie d'entre eux notamment ceux
qui ont voté michel barnier vers eric
ciotti la question c'est est ce que le
choix de la raison est aussi déterminant
parce que lorsque vous regardez
aujourd'hui les enquêtes même si vous
avez une avance pour valérie pécresse eh
bien elle n'est pas non plus tout à fait
écrasante par ailleurs et bien vous avez
un autre candidat qui a utilisé à foison
cet argument des bons sondages dans les
enquêtes d'opinion il était bien devant
le père eric ress s'est expliqué
bertrand clé pas évident que là-dessus
ce soit l'argument le plus marquant en
revanche et les pécresse a un avantage
certain sur eric ciotti en termes de
soutien de la structure du parti à voir
si on a de nouveaux cadres qui se
annie or les candidats à eric ciotti lui
mais pour l'instant on a quand même je
dirais des des barons des structures du
parti qui penche plutôt du côté de
valérie pécresse qu'eric ciotti et ça
évidemment cette donne avec pécresse un
avantage certain emery glisser votre
film tant qu'un et d'inspiration
gaulliste et réformatrices selon vous
lequel des deux candidats incarnent le
mieux ce fameux héritage général de
gaulle que tout le monde s'arrache un
petit peu il faut bien le dire oui tout
le monde aimerait bien s'arracher tout
le monde se lâche en effet nous les
études que nous avons menées depuis
maintenant plus d'un mois montré une
tendance était plutôt celle de valérie
pécresse et dans le même temps on a
aussi vu l'émergence de la candidature
d'eric ciotti qui est monté manière très
impressionnante sur les dernières
semaines et signalement ce résultat même
s'il est très serré pour les quatre
candidats qui arrive en tête il confirme
deux choses 1 ce que c'est finalement
les candidats qui ont été le plus proche
du barycentre et de logique du parti qui
s'en sont mieux sorties et un deuxième
élément c'est la performance lors des
débats télévisés qui ont une importance
croissante au fil des semaines et
finalement il ya une certaine logique
que ce soient ces deux candidats qui se
retrouve au second tour ce soir sont le
plus au centre du parti d'un point de
vue idéologique au barycentre du parti
et s'ils ont le mieux réussi leur
prestation télévisuelle alors on va les
retrouver jean philippe dugoin clément
qui est avec nous en direct merci de
nous rejoindre vous êtes donc le porte
parole de valérie pécresse merci d'être
avec nous ce soir x outils dits de sa
désormais adversaire elle a un
positionnement trop centriste trop
proche du maquereau nisme elle ne
parviendra pas à battre à emmanuel
macron de ne gagnerons pas en étant
sociaux démocrates mais en étant
réformateur que répondez vous à cela
bonsoir oui la départ parole l'un des
orateurs de
non je crois de glace et il ya la
caricature se comporte avec valérie
c'est un projet de rupture extrêmement
fort au même titre que ce qu'elle a fait
ce que nous avons fait avec elle en ile
de france on est sur un projet de
rupture très par rapport à ce que fait
le gouvernement à l'heure actuelle est
d'ailleurs n'y a aucun point commun on
est sur une page qui va se tourner et
une tâche qui va se tourner sur la base
d'un projet travail et porter construit
depuis des mois maintenant par valérie
il ya eu un travail le font absolument
colossal qui a été fait et d'ailleurs
moi je 9 que si elle a pu performer
comme elle l'a fait sur les sondes sur
les débats allaient au delà de ce
qu'imaginaient les sondages parce que
quand valérie aux proches et sa
candidature au mois de juillet comme
eric ciotti d'ailleurs peu de gens
attendaient cette finale et bien c'est
parce que l'un comme l'autre ont eu des
programmes qui sont construits on non
pas bâtie sur du sable blanc bâti sur
des éléments solides et sur un projet de
rupture par rapport à ce qui est fait
aujourd'hui alors le sujet il sera bien
évidemment de parvenir à rassembler
rassembler largement à rassembler au
delà de sa famille politique stricto
sensu et je pense que avec pécresse aura
la capacité à le faire ses fans heureux
de lier c'est vrai que eric ciotti sur
toi un petit peu sol on le disait contre
tous tout le monde appelle à voter pour
valérie pécresse vous y croyez toujours
là encore à cette surprise ciotti oui
parce que c'est une
nouvelle nouvelle campagne qui commence
même si les campagnes éclair de quelques
heures et puis le le second tour n'est
pas n'est pas le premier eric ciotti lui
se concentre et veut parler aux
militants personne n'est propriétaire
des voix des adhérents
c'est à eux de faire leur leur
cheminement par rapport à à la personne
qui semble plus à même de battre
emmanuel macron au second tour de
l'élection présidentielle
là encore
les convictions sont très fortes les
adhérents la base des adhérents
partagent des convictions d'eric ciotti
il faut faire aussi confiance à cette
intelligence collective et je pense que
également les français mais les
adhérents et les français dans leur
ensemble vous savez les additions
d'appareils politiques lisons nous un
peu permettez moi l'expression
ras-le-bol et donc qu'ils votent avec
avec leur coeur qu'ils fassent le choix
je crois du coeur et vous verrez qu'il y
aura une surprise au second tour il y en
a déjà une aujourd'hui benjamin morel
vous êtes toujours avec non c'est vrai
que les militants ceux qui ont voté
aujourd'hui c'est une toute petite
partie quand même aussi peut-être des
potentiels électeurs les républicains
sont pas nécessairement les mêmes qui
voteront pour l'un ou pour l'autre le
jour de la présidentielle n'est ce pas
ah non c'est à dire que le problème
quand vous faites une primaire sur tout
particulièrement quand vous faites une
primaire entre guillemets fermés ou avec
un corps électoral restreint c'est que
vous adressez à la base de la base de
vos militants de vos adhérents de aux
sympathisants cette base de la base et
pas forcément à l'image de votre
électorat existants et de votre
électorat potentiel
regardez ce qui s'est passé avec le
parti socialiste lors des dernières
primaires où c'est benoît hamon qui
était plutôt très très je dirais très à
gauche dans le parti qui l'a emporté qui
ensuite main a permis l'émergence d'
emmanuel macron donc là si vous voulez
pour les candidats en vue de cette
primaire est en vue demain du second
tour il faut s'adresser
basket une masse très polarisée qui est
une base très particulière et donc le
problème évidemment c'est que par la
suite les propositions qui auront été
faites dans le cadre de cette primaire
les propositions qui ont été faites dans
le cadre de de ce processus de sélection
il va falloir les assumer devant un
électorat plus large peut-être s'il
s'agit de valérie pécresse qui
l'emportent devant un électorat
centriste
cette primaire peut être un avantage
parce que ça donne une visibilité à
terme pour cette un candidat peut
également s'avérer
agir parce que c'est très juste
attention au grand écart c'est à dire
qu'on s'est ad on s'est adressé à nous à
nos adhérents chacun avec des
convictions un projet il faudrait pas
pour autant le dénaturer parce que on
veut faire l'ouverture il faut
véritablement rassembler notre famille
politique après rassembler notre base
notre base électorale elle va au delà de
notre famille politique il ya un
phénomène qui s'appelle eric zemmour
avec des constats qui sont qui peuvent
être partagés par et yu ti je pense que
nos solutions peuvent répondre aux
craintes de cet électorat là également
mais attention de ne pas gauchisé trop
notre discours pour à l'épousé le centre
faisons une campagne de premier tour
d'élection présidentielle on aura
largement de quoi rassembler entre le
premier et second tours très justement
latence la réaction d'eric zemmour qui a
forcément attiré l'attention aujourd'hui
écouter ce qui la pensée de ce premier
tour
heureux cher eric de voir nos idées si
largement partagé par les ministres
auraient l'air le rpr n'est pas mort
stéphane lhomme et de décorer les xénons
du cher eric voilà le rpr est pas mort
ça vous fait plaisir parce que il
aimerait bien se sont départis rossi
d'eric zemmour eric je tiens on l'a
entendu d'ailleurs reprendre ses
distances oui parce que l'idée encore
une fois eric ciotti et a toujours été
fidèle à sa famille politique
en fonction du résultat il soutiendra où
il se souviendra lui-même sait ce que
c'est ce que j'espère sur sur eric
zemmour quand même un constat sa
déclaration de candidature est quand
même
assez révélateur de quelque chose des
constats et aucune aucune solution
concrète pour répondre aux angoisses
qu'ont les français en matière
migratoire en matière de sécurité voilà
la différence entre un polémiste et des
hommes politiques comme valérie pécresse
et comme eric ciotti
aymeric il s'est justement on parle et
voilà de ce rapprochement peut-être de
certaines un certain point commun entre
eric ciotti et
eric zemmour al'inverse on a souvent
reproché à valérie pécresse de
ressembler un petit peu trop à emmanuel
macron qu'est ce qui pour vous justement
les différencie valérie pécresse et
emmanuel macron de l'extérieur entendre
peut-être car mip ce soit oui ben alors
le il faut il faudrait pas faire le
résonnement inverse de penser que les
réserves de voix de l air ne serait
uniquement du côté d'eric zemmour civile
dans le cas où ce sera eric ciotti qui
entre le congrès et inversement
uniquement du côté des manuels macron
dans le cas où ce serait valérie
pécresse quel que soit le candidat qui
gagnera à la fin du congrès l'enjeu sera
double pour ce candidat c'est de
rétablir un espace électoral une base
électorale beaucoup plus large que celle
qu'elle l'est actuellement et là dessus
ils ont de levier un premier levier sur
les réformes économiques alors en
appuyant là où ça fait mal d'un point de
l'électorat macro ni sur l'échec des
manuels macro à mener des réformes
structurelles sur d'un point de vue
économique et des différentes réformes
et dans le même temps aller récupérer
l'électorat fillonniste qui s'est
détachée de l air pour aller vers eric
zemmour actuellement ce à peu près 20
22% des toits fillon qui estime aux
intentions de vote revoter eric zemmour
est finalement il faudra agir sur ces
deux leviers établir élargir l'espace
électoral en allant chercher les
électeurs où ils sont c'est à dire chez
alerte chez eric zemmour est aussi c'est
emmanuel macron alors c'est pas le cas
jean philippe dugoin clément justement
de votre candidat devait léry pécresse
qui je le répète à qui on reproche
souvent d'être un peu trop centristes un
peu trop proche des manuels macron quand
on voit effectivement quand on cumule un
petit peu alors on se méfie plus que
jamais des sondages bien évidemment les
scores d'eric zemmour et score de marine
le pen c'est très très adroite
savez il ya moins d'un an des u15
ministre des mines le maquereau candidat
contre nous en ile de france si on les a
battus je vois pas où est la proximité
avec emmanuel macron là dessus alors sur
des postures de primaire très bien la
réalité c'est qu'il ya jamais eu le
moindre connivence ou le moindre lien
qui a toujours eu une femme qui
apportait un projet politique assumée
différent celui du gouvernement
comme eric ciotti comme d'ailleurs les
trois autres candidats qui ont concouru
à cette primaire au premier tour la
réalité à laquelle nous allons être
confrontés au delà de ça c'est d'arriver
véritablement à partir du 5 décembre
matin à rassembler rassembler sur un
projet de rupture à rassembler tout le
monde si nous ne parvenons pas à faire
ça le résultat on reconnaît c'est les
élections européennes qui ont terminé à
moins de 10% c'est l'antithèse de ce que
nous souhaitons porter les uns comme les
autres et nous ne pourrons nous ne
pourrons arriver effectivement un
résultat positif
on travaille ensemble en élargissant
notre base et en le faisant sur un
programme et des idées claires c'est ce
qui a été défendu pendant cette primaire
qui sert de base et qui sera la ligue
que portera valérie pécresse bien
évidemment en y associant les quatre
candidats de la primaire qui n'auront
pas emporté sept aps une heure ou deux
de manière à pouvoir rassembler 10 à 6
rex yachts et il ya une primaire
discussion sera inverse mais l'objectif
est qu'il n'y ait plus qu'un candidat
qui puisse rassembler les valérie strand
état de le faire benjamin morel alors ce
qui est coquin ce soir c'est que c'est
vrai que les deux finalistes
a priori toujours dans les études
d'opinion on est bien obligé d'en parler
même si on s'en méfie plus que jamais
n'était pas en mesure de l'emporter
justement face à emmanuel macron la
plupart du temps tranquille non
d'ailleurs n'était jamais placé au
second tour seul xavier bertrand l'a l'a
été c'est vrai que
la droite peut s'inquiéter
oui la droite est dans une situation
difficile elle a pas réellement les clés
de son destin et c'est ça aujourd'hui le
vrai problème alors la comparaison avec
les élections régionales ou municipales
tient peu en réalité la vème république
elle est fondée sur le principe de
l'alternance et pour incarner
l'alternance pour incarner l'alternative
l'alternance en ile de france et dans
les autres ans et ben c'était par
définition pas valérie pécresse xavier
bertrand il y avait un sortant donc il y
avait déjà et bien un paul et ce bolide
et l air pour les élections
présidentielles et bien le pôle est
beaucoup plus emmanuel macron il faut
apparaître comme étant l'alternative la
plus crédible à emmanuel macron sinon
bah vous a laissé passer aux européennes
vous avez une partie de lectorat et
l'eire qui votent macron parenti le
pénis mais une partie de l'électorat le
lr qui vote le pen parents team acronis
est donc cette prise en étau aujourd'hui
elle extrêmement dangereuse pour l air
aujourd'hui vous avez une base
électorale qui reste à l air qui est
généralement plutôt âgée qui est forte
identité politique et qui est fidèle si
jamais l'air veut l'emporter eh bien
elle doit s'étendre aux dépens de l'un
de ses deux pôles voir des deux mais
surtout de l'un d'entre eux et là il ya
une stratégie qu'ils disent est d'une
certaine façon échappe à l air soit il
ya un effondrement d'eric zemmour et de
marine le pen est une possibilité
d'extension comme l'ont fait d'autres
partis en europe le vp en autriche les
tommies en grande bretagne et cetera sur
cet espace politique soit il ya un
effondrement des manuels mâcon et une
stratégie de captation des centres est
possible mais à les capter comme vous
devez le faire à léry pécresse les
électeurs de centre droit en considérant
que ces électeurs de centre-droit la
préfèrerait emmanuel macron alors qu
emmanuel macron est en poste et qui
répond tout de même à leurs
préoccupations c'est compliqué à les
capter pour eric ciotti des électeurs
qui aujourd'hui sont fidèles à marine le
pen s'est également compliquer dès lors
qu'elle apparaît comme étant l'opposante
la plus structurelle emmanuel macron ce
dilemme la cette quadrature du cercle eh
bien ça fragilise et l'air depuis cinq
ans alors justement sur cette base
électorale je vous propose avant de vous
faire réagir d'écouté stanislas frigo en
génération z en proche donc d'eric
zemmour écouter ce qu'ils en pensent
pourquoi ciotti est il au second tour
parce qu'il a tenu un discours à droite
le discours d'une vraie droite la base
élèves comme nous le disons depuis des
mois réellement à droite cet effet le
relier vous êtes d'accord avec cette
analyse stanislas rigaux oui je voudrais
rebondir je suis réellement à droite en
tout cas l'a montré par rapport à la
ligne politique d'eric ciotti je pense
que c'était son slogan il est de droite
c'est une droite à assumer maintenant
sur l'élection présidentielle par
rapport au candidat sortant emmanuel
macron sur sous la vème république
jamais aucun président sortant n'a été
élu sur un programme de continuité ça
s'est vu avec françois mitterrand et
jacques chirac a eu des périodes de
cohabitation qui leur a permis d'avoir
un nouveau souffle une nouvelle offre
politique mais je pense qu emmanuel
macron fait une erreur stratégique en se
prétendant favori de l'élection
présidentielle et sans avoir ce ce
pouvoir d'auto critique sur son action
pour pouvoir proposer une nouvelle offre
une nouvelle à nouveau souffle à son
projet et donc je pense que là il ya
véritablement pour nous une opportunité
quel que soit le candidat qui sortira
d'ailleurs du congrès pour véritablement
incarner l'alternative l'alternance à
emmanuel macron est mené c'est d'accord
avec ce diagnostic est vraiment là une
opportunité ou comme on le disait que
benjamin morel c'est vrai que la lr
aujourd'hui son ton situation qui peut
de faiblesse et ne maîtrisent pas leur
destin bien sûr que les une opportunité
elle est une opportunité pour plusieurs
raisons d'abord c'est le manuel macron
qui va devoir se réinventer pour la
campagne 2022 il doit à la fois
maintenir l'esprit des réformes de 2017
pour continuer à séduire un électorat
plutôt de centre droit et en même temps
incarné la continuité porter un bilan et
être un peu le vote utile d'une partie
la gauche qui veut faire barrage à des
candidatures comme celle d'eric zemmour
et marine le pen qui pour lui sont très
anxiogène donc il doit réussir annoncé
sur ses deux pieds à la fois c'est dur
électorat de centre-droit et en même
temps continuer à être un vote utile
pour une partie de la gauche et ça va
être compliqué pour lui de l'autre côté
il ya une difficulté structurelle à la
fois pour aiguiser moore et pour marine
le pen incarné une forme d'alternance
c'est que pour l'instant dans toutes les
études d'opinion ils n'ont jamais battu
emmanuel macron
et on annonce aperçoit quand on regarde
en détail que les variations dans les
opinions de vos d'eric zemmour de marine
le pen auprès des catégories populaires
c'est qu'à peu près 10% des lectorats
qui varient pour eric zemmour quand tu
pensais qu'eric zemmour ait plus de
chance de battre marine le pen eric
zemmour c'est tellement radicalisent
dans ses prises de position et aimant
clivé l'opinion que finalement il
apparaît comme plus anxiogènes pour
l'opinion que marine le pen et 7
électoral est en train de revenir avec
marine le pen on ne peut pas exclure que
finalement n'ayant pas trouvé de choix
pertinent pour battre emmanuel macron
entre eric zemmour et marine le pen cet
électorat là ne se déporte pourquoi pas
sur candidats aient l'air pour faire
battre manama alors justement jean
philippe dugoin clément est ce que votre
poulain je sais pas comment on le dit au
féminin valérie pécresse va devoir se
droitiser justement pour tenter de
l'emporter
franchement est de se qualifier pour le
second tour ont justement on se souvient
quand même que la même valérie pécresse
en 2019 avait claqué la porte un petit
peu des républicains en disant voilà
c'est un peu trop à droite la ligne de
laurent wauquiez mois mais elle ne
convient pas à donc il va falloir faire
un petit numéro d'équilibriste
si vous permettez je crois sincèrement
la question des papes se droitiser sur
centraide savoir ace combat est ce qu
une automaticité à prendre des voix
d'emmanuel macron des voix de marine le
pen le dérégler moore la question de
fond pour nos compatriotes pour les
français c'est est ce qu'on est capable
de porter des solutions et le faire est
ce qu'on est capable d'avoir un
programme aujourd'hui au fond on assiste
à quoi il ya une extrême droite qui fait
des constats qui fait des diagnostics
mais qui est incapable portée des
solutions et il ya un gouvernement en
place qui était là depuis quatre ans et
demi et qui n'a rien fait et est
incapable de faire est le sujet qui va
se porter pour nous quel que soit le
candidat qui soit désigné le 4 décembre
hormis la question de rassembler parce
que la division tu quoi qu'il se passe
ça va être d'être crédible sur le fait
de pouvoir faire est de pouvoir apporter
des solutions et ça c'est quelque chose
qui fait sur la base d'un programme d'un
programme de rupture sur des thématiques
fortes qui sont d'économies qui sont
pouvoir d'achat qui sont la sécurité qui
sont l'éducation
et c'est sur cela qu'on gagnera ou qu on
échouera mais ça ne sera pas sur des
positionnements politiques sur des jeux
d'estrade ou en pensant qui ait une
automaticité parce qu'on s'appelle
eric ciotti ou valérie pécresse de
pouvoir rassembler de manière quasiment
automatique un peu plus sur tel ou tel
champ des lecteurs les français veulent
des solutions ils veulent des réalités
vol de l'acsi stéphane heureux de lier
le mot de la fin c'est votre candidat
perd samedi est ce qu'il va peut-être
être amené à rejoindre eric zemmour on
se souvient thème qu'il a toujours dit
qu'il voterait eric zemmour entre
emmanuel macron n'a évidemment pas nier
valérie pécresse en précisant que c'est
pas un scénario sur lequel il envisage
le second tour non clairement il a
toujours toujours dit il est fidèle à sa
famille politique depuis 41 ans
forcément si dorénavant valérie pécresse
sortait en tête du convoi et gagner ce
congrès il soutiendrait valérie pécresse
a fait aucun doute est il là il
ad'ailleurs reformuler ce soir tout
simplement pour dire que sa famille
politique et ce qu'il compte pour lui le
plus est que comme l'a dit très
justement monomode il ya place à la
division
nous sommes dans un carrefour on a une
ligne de crête pour gagner et c'est
grâce à ce rassemblement qu'on va
pouvoir faire dès le début 4 au sport
dès le 5 au matin que les français vont
pouvoir avoir une expérience porter une
espérance c'est notre responsabilité par
rapport à l'avenir de la france
effectivement vous n'avez pas être
ennemis longtemps puisque c'est samedi
est le second tour mais on n'est pas
mieux ses adversaires merci en tout cas
à tous les quatre ans brigue glis et sur
ce plateau stéphane le rudulier jean
philippe dugoin clément et benjamin
morel merci vous d'avoir été en direct
avec nous
et dont le reste de l'actualité le bras
de fer entre paris et londres sur les
quotas de pêche pose presque site les
britanniques lâche du lest à l'île anglo
normande de guernesey a décidé
d'accorder 40 licences à des bateaux
français des pêcheurs pourront donc
continuer à jeter leurs filets dans les
eaux britanniques après le 1er février
prochain grégoire douce et
la tension redescend d'un cran
une quarantaine de licences de pêche ont
été accordées par le gouvernement de
guernesey sur 58 demande émanant de
pêcheurs français cette annonce leur
permettra de poursuivre leur activité au
large de l'île anglo normande après le
1er février prochain
le bailliage de guernesey a délivré des
licences de pêche à 40 navires de
l'union européenne remplissant les
conditions requises en vertu de
l'article 502 de l'accord de commerce et
de coopération entre le royaume uni et
l'union européenne
40 licences auxquels s'ajoutent trois
autres pour de nouveaux bateaux de pêche
venant remplacer des navires qui ont
quitté la flotte française un
soulagement et une manière d'adoucir des
relations électriques ces derniers temps
entre françaises et britanniques à la
proche de la date limite fixée par la
commission européenne
l'obtention de ces 43 10 ans c'est une
excellente nouvelle pour nos pêcheurs
bruxelles avait en effet déjà imposé la
date du 10 décembre au britannique pour
régler ce sujet conflictuel au moins en
partie le gouvernement français espère
encore obtenir une centaine de licences
supplémentaires
et on l'évoquait en ce début d'émission
la réunion annuelle des ministres des
affaires étrangères de l'eau et c'est
eux qui se poursuit dans la capitale
suédoise rendez vous qui se déroule dans
un contexte de vives tensions entre
washington et moscou au sujet de
l'ukraine on retrouve à stockholm notre
envoyé spécial david kelly ça bonsoir
david les chefs des diplomaties russe et
américaine se sont donc entretenu ce
matin et ce soir sergueï lavrov a tenu
sa conférence de presse que retenir de
cette intervention
une journée sans fin pour sérier la
broche qui a dû tour à tour subir les
accusations des représentants européens
concernant l' escalade de tension à la
frontière ukrainienne c'est d'ailleurs
sur ce point qu'il a insisté lors de sa
conférence de presse le chef de la
diplomatie russe a exprimé son désarroi
vis à vis de l'otan face au manque de
considération des propositions russes
pour la paix et il accuse l'alliance
atlantique de continuer à rapprocher son
infrastructure militaire des frontières
russes il souhaite une solution dans le
cadre d'un dialogue avec les etats-unis
et l leurs alliés c'est ce dont il a été
question lors de leur entretien le
premier de prix depuis la prise de
pouvoir de joe biden avec anthony a big
n 1 cet après midi l'objectif est de
trouver un équilibre des intérêts dans
cette région mais le chef de la
diplomatie russe dénonce le comportement
agressif de l'occident envers la russie
la cordialité ne fait plus partie des
priorités européennes 1 selon ses
propres mots il espère que le reste
pourra changer la donne en ce sens
écouter nos 10 ans non pas qu'on nous
donne des garanties de sécurité mais
comme l'a dit le président poutine l'a
dit hier c'est que d'autres rêves à
l'aube aurions des
garanties générale pour chacun des
participants de ce processus europe 1 et
là je cherche même pas à deviner
à envisager même que les pays
occidentaux refusent je pense que tout
le monde a entendu le message du
président poutine ont bien pris
conscience que notre proposition tout à
fait sérieuse et nous nous la couche ont
sur le papier actuellement et je cherche
pas à savoir quelles seront les
réactions mais en tout cas ce qu'il faut
c'est regarder
de quelle façon les pays occidentaux
regarderont seront ils sérieux seront
ils s'insèrent dans la considération de
nos propositions s qui continueront à
gonfler les muscles et à me faire une
probable une propagande de militaires il
est vrai que anthony blinken a été
provocateur tout au long de la journée
même durant leur réunion ils n'accusent
l'a réussie de saboter les accords
d'helsinki signé en 1975 destinées à
renforcer la sécurité européenne ce de
minsk également et le cessez le feu
votez en 2014 le chef de la diplomatie
américaine a une nouvelle fois fait part
de sa crainte concernant l'épreuve de
force armée russe à la frontière
ukrainienne anthony blinken a été très
clair dans ses propos en cas d'invasion
russe en ukraine les etats-unis menacent
le kremlin a deux sanctions économiques
il est dit sergueï lavrov a répété
depuis ce matin tout comme elle vladimir
poutine ir qu'il n'avait pas l'intention
d'envahir l'ukraine mais que cette
présence militaire était seulement
préventive en réponse aux exercices
militaires ukrainien en tout cas si
jamais un ces sanctions on venait à être
effective le gala réussir et agirait de
manière ferme écouter
simplement nos collègues occidentaux ont
perdu la culture du dialogue la culture
des échanges diplomatiques de la
recherche de consensus malgré tout
j'espère bien que cela
je ne manifeste pas le fait dramatique
que les pays occidentaux ont perdu le
sens du dialogue mais que simplement
cette humeur
russophobe dans l'otan et dans l'union
européenne j'espère que cela ne
débouchera pas sur une confrontation
et j'espère que ces pays travailleront à
ce pour quoi l'odeur était créé cette
heure-ci à des sanctions infernale comme
ils le disent bien sûr que nous
réagirons ça y est la brf a
immédiatement quitté la capitale
suédoise après cette première journée 1
du 28e meeting de l'organisation pour la
sécurité et la coopération européenne
les sessions plénières se sont
poursuivies lors de cette première
journée avec l'intervention de
nombreuses délégations européennes et
étrangères est ce qu'on peut retenir de
cette première journée bien elle c'est
qu'effectivement c'est la mise en garde
répétées de l' escalade de tension à la
frontière ukrainienne qui pourrait
mettre en péril la sécurité européenne
l'objectif est d'optimiser les
discussions pour trouver une solution
diplomatique et stopper les
confrontations à travers le dialogue
afin d'éviter un schéma de guerre froide
un schéma de guerre froide c'est vrai
qui se redessine peu à peu à travers
l'europe d'autres sujets ont été abordés
notamment le conflit dans le
haut-karabagh ou encore la crise
migratoire à la frontière polonaise il
en sera question ce vendredi pour la
deuxième et dernière journée de ce
meeting de l'ouest merci david qualif en
direct donc de stockholm accompagné à la
caméra par renault parquet et pour en
parler pour aller plus loin nous sommes
avec dimitri de kochko
journaliste président de l'association
stop russophobie bonsoir monsieur merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
on l'a entendu échange tendu entre les
deux diplomates quel regard vous portez
sur ses déclarations
lavrov hume inexpliquée en fait il a dit
que c'est vrai que les américains et
notamment blinken a commencé tout un lot
d'accusations contre la russie sur le
fait qu'elle ne respecterait pas les
accords de minsk sur le dôme basse or la
russie n'est pas partie prenante
donc il a fait distribuer à tous les
participants de tous les ministres des
affaires étrangères de cette conférence
il a fait distribuer le texte de
désaccord de minx qui ont été donc votée
par le conseil de sécurité de l'onu je
vous rappelle et qui permettent de voir
que en fait ce sont les républiques
renom reconnu de lougansk de donetsk et
kiev qui sont partie prenante des
négociations et que la russie est au
même titre que la france et l'allemagne
un des pays observateurs est un des pays
chargés de faire appliquer ces accords
de minsk qui ne sont pas appliquées par
kiev
donc il a dit il n'empêche que nous
pouvons quand même discuté nous
considérons que c'est quand même utile
de discuter avec blinken lors de cette
conférence puisque les américains sont
en fait la puissance décisionnaires en
ukraine c'est eux qui prennent les
décisions en fait d'une part et
deuxièmement parce que monsieur bling
qu'elle m'a bien confirmé qu'il ne
cherchait pas à élargir le format de
normandie des accords de minsk c'est à
dire celui justement de la france de
l'allemagne de la russie et de l'ukraine
avec ses 2
régions qui n'ont pas accepté le coup
d'état de 2014 alors en tout cas le ton
est loin d'être cordiale entre les deux
pays ainsi la russie décide de continuer
sur la voie de la confrontation elle
subira de graves conséquences a prévenu
glinka nous à chinatown qui dénoncent
notamment une agression contre l'ukraine
moscou risque qui a une tous les sites
d'émission contre qui que ce soit c'est
exactement ce qui d'ailleurs brandi
l'idée de nouvelles sanctions mais mais
sur quelle base juridique on se demande
toujours ces histoires de sanctions
clémence était exactement que répondait
en fait lavrov dans la citation que vous
avez
que vous avez montré tout à l'heure il
parlait pas du tout deux à ce moment-là
de conflit militaire au mileu
concentration de troupes dont il
évidemment qui n'existe pas vraiment
c'est ce qu'il a dit en fait c'est que
les occidentaux malheureusement n'avait
plus que le mot de sanctions à la bouche
et qu'ils étaient en train d'en monter
sans arrêt et qu'on arrivait une ligue à
sion total de relations diplomatiques et
de capacités de négociation donc il dit
finalement entre deux les passants ça se
retourne contre ceux qui instaure en
permanence ces sanctions et dire des
conséquences notamment sur les échanges
non seulement diplomatique et politique
mais aussi économique
non il n'y a aucun fondement juridique
et même je dirais et d'un que et des
violations juridique aussi bien du droit
international disant qu'ils seraient
bien antilles par l'onu que ce qui a pu
exister au niveau des accords
commerciaux et de libre échange au
niveau mondial donc bien évidemment
qu'il ya pas de fondement juridique à
ces sanctions y'a que des fondements
politiques et du rapport de force alors
joe biden et venir poutine 1 devrait du
coup s'entretenir prochainement dans
dans la continuité de cette réunion
entre les deux hommes aujourd'hui qu'est
ce qu'on peut attendre de ce rendez-vous
plutôt une accalmie réchauffement de la
relation
c'est difficile à dire il vous savez
donc on paye des néo boutines se sont
rencontrés à genève
et c'était un moment de grande tension
là aussi notamment en ukraine est tout
le problème est là c'est que en ce
moment il y a à l'intérieur de l'ukraine
une crise politique assez forte et en
mai donc on peut craindre des des fuites
en avant notamment du présidence des
inscrits qui a été visiblement lâchée
par un certain nombre de ses soutiens
et on peut dire que il est assez
inquiétant effectivement que
cette surenchère de l'otan et de
l'ukraine qui parle de coup d'état
évidemment organisé par la russie
puisque tout ce qui se passe un
excellent toujours organisé par la
russie
que cela le fait que et l'ins qui part
du fait que l'ukraine étant est en
guerre
contre la russie alors que lui même
s'est retrouvé quelquefois à des
cérémonies à quelques pas très très loin
de la frontière russe et en toute
sécurité
c'est assez c'est assez c'est assez
inquiétant parce qu'on est à la merci de
n'importe quelle provocation qui peut
mettre le feu aux poudres effectivement
ça a été le cas déjà donc au printemps
au moment où byden et poutine se
rencontrer et il a fallu que poutine
fasse une déclaration en rappelant les
possibilités de la russie en matière de
missiles
hypersonique et qu'il a fallu que
quelques démonstrations militaires de
transport de troupes très rapide ont pu
être faites à l'intérieur de la russie
pour que
pour que joe biden défi de rencontrer
poutine et de discuter sur un autre ton
que simplement la guerre de
l'information que nous subissons tout le
temps de dans la plupart malheureusement
de nos médias en france aussi ce qui est
très dommage parce que la france n'a pas
forcément ses intérêts là et la france
est logiquement à des pays garants de
l'application
des accords de minsk or
une assistante à
merci dimitri de kochko d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur arte france merci
fin des discussions au qatar sur
l'avenir de l'afghanistan les talibans
ont de nouveau demandé aux états unis de
débloquer les fonds gelés pour l'instant
c'est non pour washington pendant ce
temps le pays elle plonge un peu plus
dans une grave crise humanitaire près de
30 millions de personnes sont menacées
par la malnutrition selon l'onu une
crise qui pourrait s'aggraver sans le
travail des femmes le régime taliban
d'imposer ses restrictions sur l'emploi
féminin a maille à souper
ces femmes pour y être la solution à un
relèvement économique en afghanistan
alors que les talibans ont imposé des
restrictions sur l'emploi féminin
l'économie ne fait que ces fonderies un
peu plus les familles ne parviennent
plus à joindre les deux bouts face à
l'augmentation du coût de la vie
quotidienne
aujourd'hui après une longue période je
suis sorti de chez moi pour faire des
achats les prix sont très élevés ça
saute aux yeux j'étais fonctionnaire
sous le régime précédent et j'ai perdu
mon emploi je reste chez moi son salaire
mon mari est également malade et sans
emploi j'ai une famille de huit
personnes et chacune d'entre elles a
besoin de nourriture et de vêtements
[Musique]
selon un rapport de l'onu publié ce
mercredi le travail des femmes
représenteraient 20 % de l'emploi total
et serez essentiel pour freiner
l'effondrement économique
aujourd'hui seuls les fonctionnaires du
domaine de la santé ou de l'éducation
sont autorisés à travailler
le programme des nations unies pour le
développement affirme que le pays le
plus pauvre d'asie aurait besoin d'une
aide d'urgence de 2 milliards de dollars
pour que chaque famille atteigne le
seuil de pauvreté alors que l'aide
internationale reste suspendue ton que
les droits humains ne sont pas
respectées
john mack
le retrait soudain et spectaculaire de
l'aide internationale constitue un choc
budgétaire sans précédent
à titre de comparaison il a fallu plus
de cinq ans de guerre pour que
l'économie syrienne connaisse une
contraction comparables cela s'est
produit en cinq mois en afghanistan en
raison de la contraction de l'aide et du
commerce
l'afghanistan ne peut plus emporté de
nourriture de médicaments d des et
d'autres produits essentiels dont il
aura besoin au cours des prochains mois
grâce à
une aide internationale qui permettait
au pays de vivre puisqu'elle
représentait 80% du budget de
l'afghanistan si aucun compromis n'est
trouvé entre la communauté
internationale et les talibans 23
millions d'afghans risque de sombrer
dans la fin de cet hiver
et direction la turquie ou la chute de
la monnaie plonge les classes moyennes
et populaires dans la crise depuis
plusieurs semaines la livre s'effondre
en un mois l'a perdu 30% de sa valeur
face au dollar en cause la baisse des
taux d'intérêt exigés par le président
turc les explications de farah mais qui
une relance impressionnante de la
croissance en turquie mais à quel prix
depuis quelques mois j'étais apte à y
perdre aux ânes adoptent une stratégie
économique fisc et l'objectif sortir la
turquie de la crise financière qui dure
depuis 2018 pour le président turc la
théorie est simple à baisser au maximum
les taux directeurs ces taux d'intérêt
fixé par la banque centrale d'un pays et
ce malgré la dégringolade de la livre
turque et l'inflation élevée dans le
pays mais le monde entier sait que je
suis contre les taux d'intérêt élevés
je n'ai jamais été pour je n'étais pas
fière et je ne serai pas demain
nous avons abandonné la politique
monétaire fondé sur des taux d'intérêt
élevés pour passer à une stratégie de
croissance basée sur les investissements
l'emploi la production et les
exportations
des mesures financières largement
décriée par les experts
par les économistes turcs mais aussi par
la population selon eux la chute de la
valeur de la livre affecte gravement
l'économie tueur ainsi que leurs
conditions de vie un dollar vaut
maintenant 12 46 presque 13 2000
jean vous savez surtout les autorités
que dieu nous aide
j'avais juste un peu de livres turques
et j'ai acheté des dollars américains
avec la livre perdre de la valeur chaque
jour alors j'ai changé mon argent turc
en dollars je suis désespéré
alors que la crise économique s'aggrave
en turquie les manifestations se
multiplient il y a quelques jours
plusieurs rassemblements ont eu lieu
dans tout le pays commerçants étudiants
opposants politiques tous demander de
meilleures conditions de vie mais il
appelait également un changement de
gouvernement
[Applaudissements]
la tension ne retombe pas entre la chine
et taïwan les avions de l'armée chinoise
aurait effectué 159 incursion dans la
zone de défense aérienne taiwanaise le
mois dernier le japon et les etats unis
ont déjà menacé d'agir militairement
françois-xavier l'envers
chaque mois ses avions de chasse chinois
cristallise la colère de taipei depuis
le début de l'année près de 900
appareils auraient pénétré dans la zone
de défense aérienne de l'île selon le
ministère taïwanais de la défense qui
dénonce une situation particulièrement
préoccupante
rien qu'en décembre plus d'une centaine
de chasseurs auraient procédé à de
telles incursions dans cet espace non
autorisées alors face à ce qu'ils
considèrent comme des provocations
les alliés occidentaux de taiwan
s'inquiètent notamment les états unis et
le japon qui redoute une invasion de
taïwan par la chine car pékin considère
l'île comme l'une de ses provinces vous
prenons l'avertissement américain
l'ancien premier ministre japonais
shinzo abe rappelle qu'une telle action
appliquerez une réponse militaire
il ne fait aucun doute qu'une invasion
chinoise de taïwan ferait courir un
risque important à la terre du japon
tant sur le plan géographique que
territoriales une urgence pour taiwan
est une urgence pour le japon est donc
une urgence pour l'alliance
nippo-américaine les gens à pékin en
particulier le président xi jinping ne
devrait jamais sous-estimer cela
face à ces menaces la chine assure
vouloir simplement tester ses capacités
de défense pour pékin les avions chinois
2 se déplace qu'à l'intérieur de
l'espace aérien national la chine
poursuit fermement une politique de
défense nationale et développe les
capacités militaires nécessaires
uniquement dans le but de maintenir la
sécurité nationale plus la chaîne se
développera mieux ce sera pour la paix
et la stabilité mondiales et le
développement commun
l'allégation selon laquelle la chine
mène des opérations d'espionnage à
grande échelle est totalement fausse
alors que chaque pays campe sur ses
positions les tensions ne devrait pas
retomber à court terme contrairement à
taïwan la chine populaire ne fait pas
partie des invités au sommet virtuel
pour la démocratie organisée par les
états unis une rencontre qui réunira 110
pays les 9 et 10 décembre prochain
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons du barrio omicron qui
risque de devenir majoritaires en europe
dans les tout prochains mois en france
métropolitaine 2 40 était confirmée une
dizaine d'autres examinent énorme
aileron sur la mobilisation ensuite des
retraites aujourd'hui à paris réformons
pas à quoi peut-on s'attendre éléments
de réponse dans l'édito échos de jacques
sapir
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le maintien de l'ordre une doctrine qui
est à la fois saluée dans le monde on
entend souvent parler d'excellence
française elle est aussi critiquée ces
dernières années quand on observe le
maintien de l'ordre en france au cours
du 20e siècle et début du 21e il ya
extrêmement peu de victimes même si mort
au maintien de l'ordre et une
catastrophe est tout à fait déplorable
on a vu des personnes gravement blessées
on a entendu aussi le terme violences
policières ce débat sur les violences
policières ce qu'il a toujours existé il
a toujours existé ou la première grande
manifestation parisienne du 6 février 34
de même pu craindre la disparition de la
toute jeune garde républicaine aux
billes dans la presse s'était déchaînée
sur ce qui était réellement le noyau dur
du dispositif de maintien d'ordre à
l'époque
[Musique]
le long chemin de la réconciliation
nationale depuis deux décennies en côte
d'ivoire au moins le processus est il
sur le point de se concrétiser le
blocage véritable se situe au niveau des
hommes politiques plus de 3000 ivoiriens
en perdront la vie lors de la crise post
électorale de 2010 2011 avec beaucoup
d'attention ça tire de partout c'était
s'était formé à l'as cozes et quand on
sortait envoyait des tasses des balles
principal envoyer des trades av en moins
d'une semaine c'était c'était le chaos
après 2010 il y avait deux camps celui
des vainqueurs et des vaincus est-ce que
la situation s'est quand même amélioré à
ce niveau le châtel que la victime se
plaignent toujours le fait est que sur
le terrain les divisions existent où
joue le fait est que le climat politique
mais pas encore véritablement apaisé
[Musique]
on a tous pensé qu'on descendait du
singe vous avez brisé ce tabou dans une
certaine mesure du genre dont deux
singes le malheur c'est que quand on dit
descente des sages on a l'impression
qu'on descende des chimpanzés et pas du
tout les chimpanzés et nous sommes
cousins germains maternelle qui était
bretonne me disais si toi tu descends du
sage mois seront pas révélées nous un
secret vous en avez mangé du mammouth je
me trouve à fouiller en sibérie et puis
un beau matin dans le trou que j'avais
commencé à creuser je trouve que les
troupes comme ce quelque chose de
billard et des grands filaments je suis
étonnée je râle je dirais que ce sont
des collègues russes qui sont venus
tripatouiller le fond de ma recherche et
puis à force de tirer dessus comme rien
ne venait je me suis aperçu que j'étais
sur le dos tu avais la mammouth
[Musique]
il est 21h merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième partie d'émission au
sommaire le variant où ils risquent de
devenir majoritaires en europe dans les
tout prochains mois alerte cet
après-midi de l' agence de l'union
européenne chargée des maladies en
france métropolitaine de cas ont été
confirmés une dizaine d'autres examinent
est confrontée à la reprise épidémique
certains hôpitaux ont d'ailleurs enclos
déclenché leur plan blanc un nouveau
conseil de défense de sécurité se
tiendra lundi en fin de matinée
lerhe 13 demandent un meilleur niveau de
vie venus de toute la france ils ont
manifesté aujourd'hui à paris à l'appel
de neuf syndicats ils estiment la
revalorisation de leur pension trop
faible eu égard à l'inflation côté
gouvernement emmanuel macron confirmé le
mois dernier qu'il n'y aurait pas de
réforme de retraite le temps de la
pandémie mais le projet n'est pas
enterré pour autant alors à quoi peut-on
s'attendre éléments de réponse tout à
l'heure avec l'élite aux échos de
jacques sapir
[Musique]
le variant au micro ne pourrait-il
devenir bientôt majoritaires en europe
c'est en tout cas ce qu'affirme
aujourd'hui l' agence de l'union
européenne chargée des maladies en
france trois cas ont été confirmés un
nouveau conseil de défense aura lieu
lundi prochain variant au micro ondes ou
encore plans blancs déclenchées dans
plusieurs hôpitaux ont fait le point sur
la situation avec cyrielle bout et
trois premiers cas omicron confirmé dans
l'hexagone ce jeudi le premier en ile de
france l'homme âgé de 50 à 60 ans rentré
d'un voyage au nigeria selon l'agencé
régionale de la santé et n'étaient pas
vaccinés le deuxième cas a lui été
détecté dans le département du haut rhin
une femme entre 40 et 50 ans qui
revenait d'un voyage en afrique du sud
mais qui était cette fois-ci vacciner
tout comme le dernier cas en date repéré
lui en vendée des cas qui pourraient se
multiplier très rapidement selon le
porte parole du gouvernement
alors à laquelle je vous parle il y a
treize cas suspects du variant omicron
sur un autre territoire ce sont des cas
suspects c'est à dire pour lesquels un
criblage à laisser penser qu'il y avait
une possibilité
varian omicron il ya déjà eu des cas
suspects depuis la semaine dernière qui
se sont révélés négatifs aux variants au
micro mais évidemment tous ces cas sont
en train d'être séquencé ne soyons donc
ni dupe ni naïf il y aura très
probablement des cas sur notre
territoire dans les prochaines heures ou
les prochains jours qui seront détectés
conséquence le gouvernement a décidé de
durcir les conditions d'entrée sur le
territoire désormais tout voyageur même
vacciné en provenance d'un pays hors de
l'union européenne doit disposer d'un
test pcr négatif durcissement aussi dans
certains hôpitaux où le plan blanc a été
déclenché notamment à colmar strasbourg
ou encore roman ce dispositif permet de
reporter certaines opérations afin de se
concentrer principalement sur les cagots
vide du point de vue médical ce que je
peux dire c'est que quand on voit les
vidéos qui circulent
sur les réseaux on voit bien que la
distanciation physique n'est pas
respectée que les gens n'ont pas de deux
masques même en dehors de moments oui y
mange donc bien évidemment ça nous
inquiète beaucoup on est dans une
société où en gros il ya beaucoup
d'individualisme font remettre du sens
commun remettent aussi du collectif et
de la solidarité entre les générations
entre les gens est vraiment con con
qu'on aille tous dans le même sens pour
essayer de s'en sortir à paris certains
hôpitaux saturent déjà face à la forte
augmentation des patients dans les
services de réanimation depuis 48 heures
il ya des patients qu'on ne peut pas
prendre parce que les réanimations son
plein on a une vraie sensation de déjà
vécu mais malheureusement les règles
n'ont pas changé une cinquième vague qui
se fait donc sentir sur le territoire le
président du conseil scientifique jean
françois delfraissy appel à davantage
d'attention afin de sauver les fêtes de
fin d'année pour les vacances de noël le
porte-parole du gouvernement gabriela
talent assure ne rien pouvoir promettre
mais restent optimistes quant à leur bon
déroulement et pour en parler nous sur
nous avec hillionnais la barre en
président du syndicat les biologistes
médicaux bonsoir à lionel merci d'être
avec nous et je précise que vous êtes
actuellement à strasbourg vous y
travaillez donc le grand test qui avait
son souvient malheureusement été
l'épicentre de l'épidémie au début il y
a deux ans aujourd'hui un chaos mikron
étaient détectés en alsace à colmar et
surtout les centre hospitalier de
mulhouse et de colmar ainsi que de
strasbourg ont déclenché le plan blanc
est ce que c'est la crainte des vieux
fantômes qui se réveille où les choses
sont tout de même bien différente
aujourd'hui
alors les choses sont différentes dans
le sens où on peut mieux testé est pour
l'instant en a moins de personnes qui
sont hospitalisées
on n'a qu'à une petite expérience sur la
crise on m'a plus de personnes qui
attrape le virus sans se retrouver
nécessairement à l'hôpital mme en
réanimation lorsqu'ils sont vaccinés en
revanche bien sûr c'est un flou pour
nous parce que ce variant comme les
autres on ne le connaît pas bien on sait
pas si les plus graves si les plus
contagieuses si les plus résistants à la
vaccination ne manque encore beaucoup de
données pour savoir ce que ça va donner
et en plus ce qu'il peut y avoir
d'autres variantes qui circulent qu'on
ne connaît pas encore d'où l'importance
en france de développer le séquençage
non seulement pour détecter le
coronavirus mais aussi voir s'il ya de
nouvelles mutations qui peuvent avoir un
intérêt médical on sait qu on a souvent
invité infinie programme que vous devez
forcément connaître c'est une sommité
dans ce domaine notamment
le séquençage c'est quelque chose qui
fait extrêmement défaut en france
manifestement est ce qu on a fait
quelques progrès depuis le début de la
pandémie
alors oui on a fait quelques progrès et
on a beaucoup poussé pour que les
laboratoires qui ont une capacité une
compétence en séquençage puisse être
appelé à la mobilisation notamment les
laboratoires privés aux côtés des
laboratoires publics mais actuellement
on a plus de capacités et ses
laboratoires là n'ont pas encore été
appelé et nous on pousse depuis le début
pour que l'ensemble des capacités en
séquençage soit utilisée en france et
notamment qu'on ait des résultats plus
rapides parce qu'à l'heure actuelle on a
beaucoup de temps entre le moment où on
envoie un résultat séquençage jusqu'au
moment où on à l'interprétation
expliquez-nous comment ça se passe ce
séquençage
vous vous êtes dans un laboratoire vous
êtes obligés d'en l'envoyer dans une
forme de laboratoire qui fait centre qui
pratiquent ce séquençage pour déterminer
quelle variante c'est bien cela
voilà exactement et on a deux types de
séquençage différent dans le sens où on
en voit d'un côté du séquençage
aléatoire c'est à dire tous les lundis
par exemple tous les échantillons
positifs sont envoyées donc là c'est la
pêche à la ligne et on a aussi du
séquençage ciblé ciblées notamment
lorsqu'on a une pcr suspecte
c'est-à-dire un criblage qui ne colle
pas avec le variant delta ce moment là
ce prélèvement là on va le sait quand
c'est parce que c'est pas du variant
delta donc on veut savoir ce que c'est
ou par exemple quand quelqu'un revient
d'un pays à risque et et qu'il a une
paix certes positif ce prélèvement là on
va aussi le séquencé puisque c'est plus
suspecte de variants au micro voilà il
ya aussi un séquençage spécifiques et
ciblées qui est fait mais encore une
fois on manque de séquençage en france
et ça prend un peu trop de temps pour
voir les résultats pour l'instant alors
ça veut dire quoi de conséquence
peut-être à cela on songe estiment
peut-être le nombre de ce nouveau
variant par exemple et peut-être aussi
le risque d'avoir un délai
pour justement connaître le chiffre
exact
alors oui bien sûr le nombre de nos
micros présents sur le territoire est
sous-estimé c'est clair maintenant
encore une fois surtout on voudrait
savoir qu'est ce que c'est que ce
variant là et en quoi ça va changer la
politique nationale on l'a vu avec le
variant delta l'isolément est passé de 7
jours à 10 jours est ce que on va avoir
une politique différente avec ce variant
micron pour l'instant on ne le sait pas
est ce qu'il va falloir changer les
vaccinations les adapter pour l'instant
on ne le sait pas pour l'instant ce
qu'on sait c'est une chose c'est que le
mieux c'est de miser sur la stratégie
tester alerté protégées dont dès qu'on a
des symptômes tout testé pour isoler la
personne éventuellement tester d'autres
virus que le govic ya pas que l'aco
villes en france et c'est bien de savoir
qui est qui et nous ont tous là
également pour pouvoir détecter qu'ovide
mais également de riz et brs ça c'est
des choses qu'on sait il ya autre chose
qui peut aider bien sûr c'est les gestes
barrières on sait malheureusement même
avec la vaccination
surtout quand elle est ancienne on peut
quand même attrapé le virus et le
diffuser à notre entourage donc il faut
toujours rester vigilant et évidemment
le troisième volet c'est la vaccination
pour l'instant ça fonctionne sur les
variants actuelle probablement également
en partie sur au micron donc misant sur
la vaccination parce que si les hôpitaux
sont débordés avec le variant delta je
ne sais pas bien on va mettre les
malades dans une semaine deux semaines
trois semaines parce que nous en
laboratoire on voit une explosion du
nombre de cas positifs et on aimerait
que ces personnes-là n'aillent pas se
retrouver à l'hôpital dans une semaine
ou deux semaines et on voit bien que les
personnes vaccinées avec une troisième
dose ont moins de risque d'être en
réanimation que les autres donc voilà il
ya trois volets c'est des choses simples
mais on a que ça pour l'instant tant
qu'on sait pas ce que c'est que cette au
micro on n'a que ça justement lunettes
parents c'était évidemment la question
suivante vous dans les laboratoires vous
venez de me le dire vous voyez qu'il ya
une forme de deux rues est est-ce qu'on
est année ils vont comparable à la
première vague à la deuxième vague bref
où c'est à peu près finalement similaire
ou peut-être moins important
alors honnêtement les équipes sont
extrêmement chargé peut-être un tout
petit peu moins quand on et novembre de
l'année dernière mais même pas je crois
qu'on doit être à un niveau à peu près
similaire avec un taux de positivité
supérieure à 10% en tout cas dans ma
région ce qui est extrêmement élevé ça
fait partie des plus hauts on a un peu
moins de personnes hospitalisées est en
réaction ce qu'on avait à l'époque
heureusement et ça c'est grâce à la
vaccination mais on a les chiffres qui
monte - dont dix huit avec mes collègues
de l'hôpital je sens qu'il ya une
tension qui monte à ce niveau là donc il
faut qu'on soit extrêmement vigilants
tous ensemble et je sais pas bien si ça
continue d'augmenter à cette vitesse là
nous par exemple on a doublé le nombre
de pcr depuis la semaine dernière donc
en une semaine on a fait x 2 si on
continue comme ça dans une semaine ou
dans deux semaines on y arrivera plus
parce que là on commence à toucher
doucement les limites de nos capacités
de nouveau qu'il faudra faire pour être
vigilant là dessus
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup lionel
baroan président du syndicat les
biologistes médicaux de nous avoir
éclairé en direct sur arte france ce
soir
la cnil avait des preuves concrètes sur
l'efficacité du pass sanitaires et perd
patience depuis septembre 2020 la
commission nationale de l'informatique
et des libertés a réitéré quatre fois sa
demande de donner au gouvernement les
explications en images
[Musique]
il
les retraités demandent un meilleur
niveau de vie venus de toute la france
ils ont marché aujourd'hui à paris à
l'appel de neuf organisations syndicales
selon les manifestants la revalorisation
des pensions de base en 2020 est
insuffisante un rassemblement suivi par
notre reporter n'avait j'adhère à zac
retraités si maltraité c'est l'un des as
longue en scandé tout au long de cet
après midi pour cette manifestation qui
a débuté place denfert rochereau pour se
terminer ici même dans le secteur d'un
valley de manifestations à l'appel de
neuf organisations syndicales dont la
cgt fsu solidaires ou encore la force
ouvrière l'objectif est bien et c'était
de défendre les retraites le pouvoir
d'achat la sécurité sociale ou encore
les libertés individuelles
le pouvoir d'achat depuis à 2014 a
baissé de 10 à 12% disent ces
organisations syndicales et la
revalorisation des pensions de 0,4 pour
cent cette année et bien n'a pas permis
de combler la hausse du coût de la vie
la hausse des prix de l'énergie je vous
propose à ce sujet à d'écouter certains
manifestants pour évidemment l'art
variations de retraite bon parce que là
par exemple on vient d'avoir un petit
pourcentage mais bon ça fait pas le taf
parce que si vous voulez bon - grosso
modo puis-je en retraite j'ai beau me
10% quoi donc 10 % c'est quand même pas
rien et puis encore moi je suis pas un
des plus malheureux par rapport à
d'autres voilà à mu en compte les pièces
à la fin du mois oui parce que
j'ai alors je veux donner le montant de
ma retraite comme j'ai une carrière
courte comme la plupart des comme comme
beaucoup de femmes donc je touche 575
euros de retraite par mois et je vis
seule avec ça le but essentiel de ses
attaques contre les retraités c'est
vraiment deux cas c'est le régime par
répartition est montré notamment aux
générations qui arrivent qu il vaudrait
mieux un système par capitalisation
parce que regarder les retraités comme
et finalement on le rassure pas un
avenir quoi vous l'aurez compris les
manifestants réclament une augmentation
des pensions de retraite et une retraite
minimum équivalent au smic ils ont
profité de cette manifestation pour
protester contre la réforme des
retraites voulue par emmanuel macron un
projet de réforme qualifiée d'injuste et
de moins avantageux que le système de
calcul actuel des manifestants qui ont
aussi interpellé les candidats à
l'élection présidentielle il souhaite en
effet que les retraites que la situation
des retraités et pèse dans le débat de
la campagne électorale et les syndicats
toujours mobilisés sur cette question
des retraites on vient de le voir et
côté gouvernement on marche sur des
oeufs début novembre emmanuel macron son
souvient confirmé qu'il n'y aurait pas
de réforme le temps de la pandémie mais
le projet n'est pas enterré pour autant
alors à quoi peut-on s'attendre à une
réforme paramétrique structurel ou les
deux à la fois place tout de suite allé
dit aux échos de jacques sapir
[Musique]
bonsoir jacques d'être avec nous sur ce
plateau alors à quelle sauce on va être
mangés en 2022 ce que cette réforme un
temps annoncée elle va arriver déjà et
qu'elle forme surtout va-t-elle prendre
vous avez tout à fait raison on est
aujourd'hui absolument dans le flou la
seule chose que l'on sait c'est que en
2017 lors de la précédente campagne
macron s'était engagé à faire une
réforme structurelle la fameuse réforme
a parfois puis dans le cours du mandat
il avait commencé à évoluer sous la
pression des doigts philippe vers l'idée
que ça comprendrait aussi des éléments
de réforme paramétrique et là ce qui
nous a annoncé dans son allocution du 9
novembre et bien en réalité c'est une
réforme purement paramétrique avec un
allongement de l'âge de départ à 64 ou
65 ans donc en cinq ans mais il a fait
les quelques centimètres qui le séparait
de françois fillon tout ça pour ça et
alors quels sont les arguments en faveur
d'un simple allongement de l'âge de
départ à la retraite alors il est
fondamentalement il ya deux arguments le
premier c'est évidemment évidemment
l'allongement de la durée de vie et ça
on le voit bien
2950 à 2019
l'espérance de vie a augmenté de 16 ans
pour les hommes et pour les corps il ya
toujours un fort décalage il ya grosso
modo 4 années de décalage entre les
femmes et les hommes mais grosso modo on
a pris 16 ans depuis 1950 mais c'est pas
du tout le cas sur le lhc de l'espérance
de vie en bonne santé et ça c'est quand
même extrêmement important parce que ça
veut dire est ce que les gens
profiteront d'une certaine manière de
leur retraite et là ce que l'on voit
c'est que bon pour les hommes ça
progresse mais très légèrement pour les
femmes c'est grosso modo instable et
c'est stable à 64 ans alors en plus ce
que l'on sait aussi c'est qu'il ya
d'énormes différences suivant les
catégories sociales
on sait que les employés les ouvriers
pour eux la vie l'espérance de vie en
bonne santé elle se situe plutôt autour
de 60 ans il ya même certaines
professions ou c'est 58 59 ans par
contre pour les csp + etc spdit plus
plus on est plutôt autour de 68 70 ans
donc là il ya un vrai problème et on
voit très bien que tout allongement de
l'âge de départ à la retraite eh bien ça
va pénaliser prioritairement les
personnes des classes populaires et le
deuxième argument alors deuxième
argument bas c'est tout simplement un
argument de coincer c'est ce que coûtent
aujourd'hui le système de retraite et
c'est très net il voulait aujourd'hui la
france dépense à peu près 14 % 13 8% du
pib dans ces retraites alors c'est
nettement plus que l'allemagne
l'allemagne et autour de 10% plus que
l'espagne qui doit d'être autour de 12%
beaucoup plus que la suède qui est à ces
% donc on voit bien qu'il y a un
problème de coût et c'est peut-être à
cette notion de coût beaucoup plus qu'à
la question oui comme on vit plus
longtemps il faut qu'on puisse
travailler plus longtemps c'est beaucoup
plus à la question du coût que
réagissent des politiques alors et
stages axa ne sera pas soutenable un
avenir et bien en fait si et c'est ça
qui est intéressant c'est que le conseil
d'orientation des retraites viendra à
publier en 2020 un rapport et on voit
que en réalité ça va beaucoup dépendre
du taux de croissance de l'économie
française on voit bien que si on est
avec un taux de croissance de 1,5 ou
même 1,75
eh bien ça va être tout à fait
soutenable et même à partir de 2025 2030
on va commencer à faire baisser la dette
de retraite autrement dit l'argent que
le système de retraite a été obligée
d'emprunter et le poids général des
retraites dans le pib va baisser par
contre effectivement si on se retrouve
avec un taux de croissance très faible
par exemple 1% par an la wii ce n'est
pas soutenable donc ce que l'on voit
c'est que c'est bien joli de parler
de l'allongement de la durée de la vie
et de ce genre de choses mais que la
vraie variété l'avarié à pied réellement
pertinente c'est beaucoup plus le taux
de croissance alors qu'elles sont
maintenant les arguments en faveur de la
réforme structurelle alors sur la
question de la réforme structurelle
c'était essentiellement un problème
d'équité et d'égalité entre les
personnes et c'est vrai si vous voulez
ça je ne discute pas le fait qu'il y ait
des situations très inégalitaire
pourquoi parce que et c'est en
particulier le cas dans les régimes
spéciaux que l'on voulait et que l'on
veut supprimer 1 dans le cadre d'une
telle réforme eh bien on prenait mais ya
50 ans 60 ans on prenait des professions
qui était très pénible et dans certaines
de ces professions de la pénibilité elle
a fortement diminué c'est le cas c'est
très bien des cheminots s'est pas du
tout la même chose d'être cheminots dans
une motrice à vapeur et de l'être
maintenant dans un tgv mais d'un autre
côté on voit qu'il ya toujours des
professions qui reste extrêmement
pénible et ça se voit si vous voulez sur
le fait que l'âge de départ ou disons
l'espérance de vie en bonne santé reste
inférieur à 60 ans donc on voit très
bien qu'il ya toujours des professions
qui sont très pénibles et ça pose un
problème c'est que un système par points
ce qui était proposé par emmanuel macron
c'était aussi proposé par la cfdt il
faut le dire bon un système par points
s'il ne prend pas en compte ces
différences de situation entre les
professions et entre les personnes eh
bien il va aboutir à reproduire d'autres
inégalités qui seront tout aussi
important et c'est un problème général
chaque fois qu'on rentre dans une
logique vous savez une taille pour tout
le monde le fameux
des entrées et bien là on va se
retrouver avec des phénomènes
d'inégalités extrêmement important dans
ce cas on se demande pourquoi emmanuel
macron tient autant à cette réforme
je pense qu'il ya trois raisons qui
peuvent se combiner d'ailleurs lors la
première évidence une raison purement
politiciennes il sait que la question de
la réforme des retraites elle plaît
beaucoup à l'ancien électorat de
françois fillon d'ailleurs là et il est
en train de se calmer et prom
progressivement sur les propositions
économiques de françois fillon est donc
bon voilà on va faire une réforme
paramétrique comme le demandent et
fillon comme s'il pourra dire voilà j'ai
fait ce que votre ancien candidat a fait
donc ça c'est une première un raison une
deuxième raison qui est tout à fait
possible c'est que ben voilà
l'union européenne demande à la france
depuis des années de faire cette réforme
et on sait bien emmanuel macron est un
grand européen et voilà il peut
peut-être vouloir la faire justement en
raison de cette demande urbaine et puis
une troisième raison qui me semble quand
même tout aussi pertinente c'est que
qu'est ce qui va se passer avec cette
réforme cette réforme
admettons qu'ils fassent justement sa
combinaison de réformes structurelles et
de réformes paramétriques sava
désavantager les personnes des classes
populaires de plus de 40 ans par contre
les entrepreneurs
de moins de 30 ans ou de moins de 35 ans
eux seront avantagés dans ce système et
finalement c'est une philosophie qui
correspond assez bien à
tout ce qu'on a entendu dans la bouche
de d'emmanuel macron les premiers de
cordée et inversement les gens qui ne
sont rien c'est a donc finalement c'est
assez cohérent de sa part de vouloir
faire cette réforme merci beaucoup
jacques sapir d'avoir été avec nous et à
la semaine prochaine absolument
ces directions présent marseille avant
de refermer cette émission la cité
phocéenne qui a rendu hommage
aujourd'hui asie n'est de redouane
décédé il ya trois ans pour jour pour
jour l'octogénaire avait été touché par
un tir de grenade lacrymogène en marge
d'une manifestation de gilet jaune
aucune sanction n'avait été prise contre
le crs identifier son dos qui était
classé sans suite les explications des
stèles farges c'est le dernier de
développement dans la sphère in habré
douanes le crs mis en cause dans la mort
de cette femme de 91 ans ne sera pas
renvoyé en conseil de discipline
décision du directeur général de la
police nationale contre l'avis de l'igpn
dans les conclusions de son enquête
administrative l'inspection générale de
la police nationale préconisée elle un
conseil de discipline estimant que le
crs avait bien réalisé un tir
réglementaire mais que la mesure du
risque n'avait pas été réellement prises
en compte
dans son rapport transmis le 20 mai
l'igpn a estimé que le crs avait bien
réalisé un tir réglementaire sans viser
délibérément la victime mais avait
manqué à l'obligation de discernement
par une action manifestement inadaptées
selon la source proche du dossier
le patron de la police a classé la
sphère pas de sanction donc pour le crs
auteurs du tir ni pour son binôme en
charge de le surveiller ça ne m'étonne
pas nous n'attendions rien de la
hiérarchie policière le plus important
c'est que le crs comparaissent devant
une cour d'assises pour meurtre pour
rappel en mai 2020 un rapport
d'expertisé balistique avait conclu à un
tir effectué dans les règles c'est à
dire en cloche et à une mort
accidentelle en novembre 2020 une contre
enquête indépendante menée par le média
disclose et le groupe de recherche
londonien forensic architecture avaient
en revanche conclu à un tir tendu une
pratique interdite face à un immeuble
d'habitation notez que si l'information
judiciaire est toujours en cours
aucune éventuelle mise en examen n'a été
communiquée jusqu'à présent par la
justice
et c'est la fin de cette émission rendez
vous à partir de lundi pour un nouveau
numéro 2 d'ici là n'oubliez pas de
réagir et l'actualité continue
évidemment toute la soirée en direct sur
rtl france
[Musique]
c'est ça le point commun entre la france
et la russie c'est le samedi 11 entre
les civilisations russe française
l'importance du monde artistique c'est
une histoire lumineux au sérieux chaque
tableau qu'un l'histoire d'un monde il
derrière un tableau de dali il y avait
là c'est quand même une femme
extraordinaire gala m'a dit je voulais
vlademir signé les hommes comme les
autres signes et les oeuvres ce trait
modère ce qu'elle a raconté ça nous
rappelle aussi le désarroi amoureux de
notre époque c'était une histoire de
modernité